and finally new rule if you haven't seen
all the crime happening lately on your
tv it's probably because someone stole
it
[Applause]
as we head into the midterm election
season one issue that has risen to the
top of voter concerns is a general
feeling these days that the social order
is breaking down that there are no more
safe spaces anywhere
street crime home invasions carjacking
porch pirates
medical staff attacked at hospitals
incivility at sports arenas
and i think the grubhub driver is eating
my french fries
[Applause]
on airplanes now the in-flight
entertainment is a fistfight
[Applause]
this year the la city council voted that
every homeless tent had to be removed
from dozens of locations yet
every freeway overpass still looks like
history's saddest coachella
the homeless are both preyed upon
and frankly a concern that they will do
god knows what
you go out for a run in your
neighborhood and you have to wonder
whether that guy eyeing you on the
corner is going to be this guy or this
guy
[Applause]
we have a new thing in l.a called follow
home robberies where gang members stake
out nice restaurants and then follow
home
the people who leave in expensive cars
and forced their way into their houses
that's why paris hilton now drives a
2009 pt cruiser and
[Applause]
a day doesn't go by where you can't find
video of the latest smash and grab
robbery where thieves in broad daylight
just smash the front windows of ritzy
stores and take all the jewelry they can
carry
they went to jared
[Applause]
[Applause]
and when did they legalize shoplifting
there used to be shame in shoplifting or
at least some skill
now criminals just brazenly walk out of
walgreens again in broad daylight
[Music]
with a trash bag full of aisle three
while the security guard just watches
they have to keep even the most mundane
products all caged up cvs isn't a store
it's a zoo for teeth whitening strips
[Applause]
san francisco in the last few years has
seen 11 walgreens and six cvs stores
just give up and close because
that town seems simply beyond law which
is heartbreaking because i like so many
people love that city and i don't think
it's corny to admit yes i left my heart
in san francisco also my wallet and
[Applause]
iphone thank you
[Applause]
bay area citizens have been complaining
in recent years about all the human
feces in the streets but
now the streets are full of something
else they call it san francisco snow
it's glass piles and piles of shattered
glass everywhere from car windows being
smashed it's so routine to have this
happen to any parked car that people
purposefully leave the windows down and
the glove compartment open so thieves
can see there's nothing of value or they
leave a note on the car politely
assuring the thief that there's nothing
worth stealing and please don't break
the windows
dear mr criminal
i hope this note finds you well
[Applause]
please don't break my windows thanks
you're the best
p.s there's a walgreens around the
corner if you want to hit that
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
what is so disturbing here
is not just that there's more crime than
mayhem it's the audacity of it all
like there's no lines anymore that can't
be crossed like don't walk on a stage
during a live show
[Applause]
or don't [ __ ] with mike tyson
just
lines
people lines
i mean who needs the metaverse when you
can do whatever you want in real life
[Laughter]
the police
still need reform yes but we can't just
allow them to be hunted and targeted for
assassination as has happened over a
hundred times in 2021.
i know there are big issues behind crime
like income inequality and racism that
need to be addressed but let's not get
so wrapped up in becoming great again or
building back better that we forget not
to become el salvador
democrats like to point out that crime
has actually been worse before yes true
and who gives a [ __ ]
i'm not living before i'm living now
in 2020 america experienced its largest
annual increase in homicides ever
assaults are up mass shootings are up
voters focus is safe streets
not making women swimming safe for men
[Applause]
democrats can tell voters it's not so
bad or that they're stupid and racist
and we don't want their votes anyway but
this guy does
this american carnage stops right here
and stops right now
yeah i'll keep the [ __ ] the shoe level
[Applause]
that is a powerful campaign theme when
there's that feeling that things are
descending into every man for himself
lawlessness new york was like that in
the son of sam 70s only back then we had
taxi driver
now we
[Applause]
now we have uber driver
[Applause]
he doesn't kill pimps but his podcast is
called are you talking to me
you